hello my name is jacob and i'm a
filmmaker with great big story
i'm isolated on a boat and like everyone
else in the uk i'm now only allowed one
form of exercise a day alone with
members of your household normally i
work in london but now i'm working from
home and i'm bored
really really bored
not that my job is boring if you're
listening
boss amber i think that sounded sincere
enough now i'm pretty lucky my fiance
amber and i live on a beautiful river in
a houseboat which i've nearly finished
building
but i'm the kind of guy that will go
insane if i don't have a project already
swords challenge just because the whole
world's a bit doom and gloom at the
moment doesn't mean you can't do
something good
and that's where great big story comes
in we travel all over the world well we
did travel all over the world obviously
that isn't happening anymore
we meet met some of the most
inspirational people doing the most
amazing things so i thought why not take
a leaf out the gbs book and try and do
some good whilst isolating at home
last year i made a film about lizzie
carr a paddleboarder dedicated to
cleaning up the world's inland waterways
i looked at my own surroundings and saw
loads of litter lining the banks of the
river so over the course of a normal
five-day work week i'm going to use my
one outing a day to stuff my kayak with
as much plastic as i can
the goal to pick up 1 000 pieces of
plastic
a week of work kayaking and doing some
good for the planet along the way
it's a win-win really
although i'm pretty sure i've chosen the
busiest work day tomorrow to start this
challenge on
early start then
yeah right
let's see if i can actually do it
so i'm just boiling the kettle for a cup
of tea
trying to get up the dawn
don't think about it
it's pretty cold it's about one degrees
it's a bit cold
my paddle's frozen oh jesus
this is not going very well
yes
this is it off we go
[Music]
off with jolly well go
[Music]
this is pretty epic though
oh what a morning
oh here we go this is a
bit of plastic
vodka
oh my word it's
freezing it's about zero degrees
here
which oh american viewers um
fahrenheit i think it's like 300
fahrenheit something like that yeah
about that um
so it's really cold it is very wow
i'm stuck in the bushes
i get it i get it i get it i'm awake i'm
awake
hey siri
hey siri
hey siri
shut up polystyrene
that is the worst because it breaks up
into little bits
okay
prepare yourself to be in some bushes
jacob
oh god
this is more degrading than i thought it
was going to be
i thought you'll be fine on camera jacob
you'll be fine
you won't look like that much of an
idiot
[Music]
i've got very good at picking stuff up
in my paddle and throwing it behind me
let me do that again
yes
[Music]
oh my god this is the most amount of us
i've seen oh my god that's outrageous
tuesday time okay
here we
go come on
don't put that shot in let's not show my
boss that one
got full boat
i think it's time to head home
[Music]
oh my legs
that whole part of the boat is full of
plastic
it is stuffed
[Music]
this is probably the time i should tell
you about how energized i've been after
getting up early in the morning come on
mate don't lie to them i'll sit straight
through you yeah i know do you want a
cup of tea mate
yeah go on then all right
[Music]
so
we've got some improvements for today
first one
oh can't lean over to show you
this there's a box behind me
because i haven't got enough space in
the boat to get enough plastic for what
i need so i've added a box
but chiefly
i've got a litter picker
yes
so i picked up 112 pieces of plastic
yesterday
which is not enough it's a lot but it's
not enough the target is now 222 pieces
of plastic for the next four days
to reach a thousand
one of those frisbee discs
absolutely not
is that a lemon
another trainer
[Music]
we've got quite a lot but we got more to
fill
it
robin's in bedfordshire
love it
[Music]
no
no
no sunglasses oh hello
i'll go turn you around sorry
[Music]
well
the sun's set
we've got a full boat
it's time to go home now
what a lovely evening
oh
there we go
oh
[Music]
day three
the cold wet
rainy
gray
miserable
day
on an english plastic ridden
river
dude
[Music]
learn to be graceful jacob
learn to be graceful
another lemon
another lemon
why
who spilled all the lemons
[Music]
we had another coronavirus update
yesterday
and it looks like we're gonna have
pretty strict social distancing rules
for
at least six months
[Music]
my wedding's in five months
so having to look into cancelling our
wedding
but i know a lot of people have got it a
lot worse
than we have
this pandemic has affected many people
in a lot of very negative ways
[Music]
so the fact that i can still come out
once a day
on my kayak pick up plastic
count the amount of lemons i find
it's a real positive
[Music]
there's a lot of people that can't even
go out there's another lemon
there there's a bit of light in the dark
there's another lemon it's about sixth
lemon of the day
is it weird that the lemons are cheering
me up
but
the rivers are still full of plastic
[Music]
but i am worried that the target of a
thousand pieces of plastic
is too much
oh
oh that's like bottle heaven
hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
one
two
three
four five
oh it's raining
oh it's raining
[Music]
it was rubbish
why
why are you here doing this jacob oh
wait i know why it was your idea
ten
you are joking
[Music]
what is it
[Music]
with lemons
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
staggering how much plastic is in the
rivers
it's staggering
and scary
[Music]
i haven't filled it up
oh i'm worried i'm getting further
behind my
target
[Music]
when the end
to day three
quite fitting after a cold wet
rainy
day
oh
[Music]
long busy day at work
um
haven't really seen my paddles
in panic mode a bit at the moment just
getting last minute camera equipment
because it's getting late
the sun is about to set and haven't been
out today
i need some food for dinner
amber darling you've seen my coat
you join me in panic mode because i have
not got enough daylight
to get enough plastic for today
i think i need about 250 pieces of
plastic
[Music]
to make tomorrow
easy
as it stands
i'm gonna have to get up at door
[Music]
i'm gonna have to work harder and faster
[Music]
than all other days so far
so do i need i need my sunglasses
okay
hit that upbeat montage music
no
all of this only counts as one
for free
speed
bang move on
[Music]
it's dinner time i panicked a bit not
gonna lie
half a ton of heinz baked beans
some granola
and some tin sardines from a great big
story documentary we made
a year or two ago
[Music]
listen to the birds
oh i can see the boat the lights are on
the fire's lit
is calling for me
day four over
just tomorrow left now
i think tomorrow's gonna have to be a
really big day
dawn start i think
[Music]
home
i don't even know if you can see that
[Music]
this feels oddly reminiscent
i don't know why i'm doing it again
i've done it again
so for the final time
let's go clean that river
we've got a new addition though of
another bucket
on the front of the boat
well hey
now we've got two buckets
[Music]
for the final time off
we
jolly well go
[Music]
hey siri
hey siri hey siri hey siri hey siri
shut up
i'm actually going to be counting every
piece today
oh good morning my phone says it's
currently minus one
minus one what's that found i think
that's like minus 20.
something like that
[Music]
[Music]
because we have to get up to the grand
total of 390 pieces to complete a
thousand
nine
ten
found some deodorant does it work
oh
[Music]
rubbish
[Music]
100 yay
first monster check
not many bushes left to explore
you join me
as i'm about to get our 200th piece for
the day
here we go
oh how fitting
our 200th piece of the day is
more vodka
tell you what though this week has
really made me appreciate how lucky
how lucky we are
and that's not to take away from anyone
who's had
a terrible time of it
because there's a lot of people that had
a really terrible time of it
[Music]
hopefully in some small way
we've done something good
let's get this done
partly why it's been so slow today
has been the fact that we've already
swept this river twice now
and it seems to have made a difference
it's been great
[Music]
it's been great
amber
we've got a visitor
amber's on the paddle paddleboard
brilliant
hello
[Music]
this is great
what are you doing here
[Music]
amber how many pieces have we got left
it's a lemon i told you there's so many
lemons
amber's in the bushes
it's where we met
[Music]
this is great
now we've got a proper team
about 50 to go
there were times this morning though i
was just like oh god let's just get it
done
let's just get it done
but actually i'm now i don't want it to
end
because we're nearly there
we've got a race
yes
[Music]
26 to go
oh i'm glad
i'm glad i've learnt to be graceful
i was really worried a couple days ago
that we weren't going to do this
but we are actually going to make it
980 pieces down
20 to go
[Music]
a fishing float
[Music]
999 in
we're so close
[Applause]
one more amber
okay
oh come on
come on
this is ridiculous the whole i've been
complaining about plastic for days and
now when i want to actually find some
plastic
i can't
i can't believe it
i spent all this time
just picking up plastic because it's
everywhere and we're on 990
and we've been 10 minutes and can't find
a single piece we've been down half the
river
what
where where where oh a plastic bottle
no way
900 no a thousand
a thousand pieces of plastic
q celebratory music
i can't believe we did it
[Music]
a thousand pieces of plastic gone
we did it
and we finished with a plastic bottle
how fitting
oh
oh i hope the celebratory music is still
going
[Music]
that was brilliant
i've had such a good week
[Applause]
hello mate i know the meeting's supposed
to start but i've just completed my
challenge of a thousand pieces of
plastic
so i'm gonna go and have a cup of tea
thanks
[Music]
just have a cup of tea and reflecting on
this whole week in that stereotypical
way that vloggers do
but it has
been funny odd week
the best part by far was that last kayak
home through a river with no plastic in
[Music]
as it should be as as that river was
intended to be
and now i'm just chilling in my bath
which is a really weird thing to say now
i think about it this is going to be
like a flower garden or a veg patch
we're going to fill it and do it so
don't worry
well that's still weird that's still
probably weird
oh god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you